daniel pilon vient récupérer sa voiture
à la fourrière municipale de montréal le
20 septembre dernier elle a été saisie
par un policier qui le soupçonnait de
conduire avec les facultés affaiblies ne
peut pas la conduire à vingt deux mois
quand parce que la pénalité de trois
mois ce soir là ils assistent au
spectacle de son idole de jeunesse sur
le chemin du retour il se fait
interpeller par un policier
tout d'un coup il ya dix coups dont
monsieur vous avez bien les yeux rouges
daniel pilon est particulièrement
sensible depuis le décès de son fils
c'était motif ce parce que je pense à
mon fils qui était décédé cet été
peut-être meilleur et avec moi en plus
des yeux rouges
l'agent note que daniel pilon et nerveux
et semble confus ils lui demandent de
souffler dans un appareil de détection
approuvé
daniel pilon s'exécute mais après deux
secondes
ils s'arrêtent les mots dit que j'avais
fait exprès pour arrêter jeudi
je suis pas capable j'ai pas sauf daniel
pilon souffre d'asthme sévères explique
son pneumologue
dans ces situations de stress c'est
probable qu'il ne pouvait pas vider son
expiration plus de l'e2c con après trois
échecs le policiers procèdent à son
arrestation pour avoir refusé
d'obtempérer l'oeil m'ont mis les mains
dans le dos l'oeil noir mis comme ça
n'est mort et quartiers les jambes par
deux fois
ok l'oeil en fait la fouille
ensuite ils m'ont mis dans le véhicule
un témoins certifient sous serment que
daniel pilon n'a pas consommé d'alcool
pendant le spectacle
d'ailleurs dans son rapport le policier
note que monsieur pilon ne sent pas
l'alcool et qu'il n'a pas de difficulté
à se tenir debout
il ajoute toutefois qu'il n'est pas
essoufflé lorsqu'il parle moi j'ai pas
la règle est présentement à pied
j'étais assez matic qui je fais des
crises d'asthme à répétition il devrait
avoir de la formation auprès des corps
policiers
même si son procès au criminel n'a pas
encore eu lieu
daniel pilon subit déjà les conséquences
de son incapacité à souffler dans
l'appareil voitures saisies pendant 30
jours
permis suspendu pendant un minimum de
trois mois
c'est l'enfer et à emprisonner ma vie
dans le fond alors qu'il n'y a aucune
preuve qu'il avait bu le soir de son
arrestation
ici françois dallaire radio canada
montréal